I'm a new guard I'm leaving real quick
get me a Bey honey hi my name is Joyce
and I'm American hi my name is Tolar I'm
Armenian American even though I grew up
in America I grew up with a really
strong army and culture like in my house
my mom cooked every night Armenian food
all the time have you ever had our
meeting food before I don't think so
probably not you know I'm just really
excited to try these snacks because I
know that I deserve a home in every
single country and if I go to each
country knowing what snacks I live then
it's gonna be easier for me to find out
that's all I want
so let's bring in the snacks
[Music]
so this is a break this one is with say
that again but egg blue egg yeah so it's
basically like cheese and bread it's
just a rendition of basically a grilled
cheese okay well you know what a grilled
cheesus oh yeah pretty great my dad
taught me how to make a grilled cheese
and of course to go to his craft
American slices my mom never made
grilled cheese sandwiches actually like
I never had them growing up wait really
yeah really
we didn't even have American bread in
her house we only had pita bread spread
it for the best all right so let's slop
okay okay this is the first time I got a
full plate I'm so excited
where can I get this I mean in bakery
I'll hit you with something on the table
please - this is insane sh-boom
yeah and it's like really cheap I think
they're like $1 for like a whole 100
dollar mm-hmm honey I'm bout to go to
that Armenian line with my bread this is
much more contained mm-hmm I think the
grilled cheese it's because you have to
put butter on the bread for it to brown
right it's just it's just part of the
process it's just like you're a basic
I'm a good old American grilled cheese
it tastes pretty good not something I
really want to buy you know but you know
I have to go with that one ah that's
just like that's like home for me so
yeah I prefer the Buddha this is easier
to make but this I feel like is just if
you have some which is easier to heat up
and have your psyche I'm sure awesome
cheese and bread so this is called ton
it's basically like an army and yogurt
drink they sell it at army and bakeries
you usually drink it with the buttocks
or like something called lama-june
which is like a Armenian
Pizza almost like a flatbread like just
imagine Greek yogurt plain love it water
okay
salt hmm and you just yogurt drink
interesting this is what you Bonnie
yogurt drink it's why I like a yogurt
but I feel like strawberry banana is a
pretty failsafe flavor all right here
you go
it looks like milk it's a lot more
watery but I think I was expecting for a
yogurt drink you like it
I do it's st. more savory than I thought
it was gonna be and I think they put
salt in it it's like a smoothie oh it's
super salty you I can see why this would
be good on a hot summer day maybe like I
like it after a workout mm-hmm mm-hmm
which I definitely do old yeah this was
actually really good it tastes like your
standard strawberry banana yogurt except
it's a drink this is great as a snack I
wouldn't just like pulled a ton out and
drink it on its own but I would this one
I think I wouldn't just pick this up and
drink it it doesn't really evoke like
any feelings for me but it says protein
rich so it just says rich so you don't
really ever and you never know if I had
to choose I'd go with that guy like so
much there's so much nostalgia if I had
to probably the true bonds
I like this one look at this we're
choosing the other sides
I love unity fruit strap oh yeah baby
these babies alright this is like
basically a fruit bar
so in Armenia they call it la bas check
the one you're trying today is
pomegranates okay this was like the norm
when I was a kid like kids would come to
school with fruit roll-ups I'd come to
school with my fruit leathers I mean we
got a rollup everyone knows that's the
classic the best ones to get were the
ones that had tattoos on them because
then you just take it kind of like on
your tongue wow this whole bar oh this
one is a tattoo ones is it yeah I mean
it's not a shade queen issue I am a
fruit leather fan yeah this is very tart
but it's probably more natural probably
way up here like my family calls it la
vache but the other name for it is
lavash tattoo and tattoo literally means
sour mmm yeah
two two two this is a classic I had it
in my lunchbox at school you definitely
like taste how sugary it is and like how
processed it is whereas those you could
tell it's homemade you could tell it's
fresh you can tell it's mean I have real
fruits oh no don't rip it
okay there it is I forgot these things
existed for a while I'm so happy this
makes me feel like a little piece of a
little piece of and then the fruit part
is that I think it was just not what I
was expecting so I didn't change my
expectations a little bit
I'll go with that one
this one I'm gonna get sick of eating
like almost immediately even after
making a tongue tattoo this one is the
kind of thing like you tear a piece you
eat it you
down you can come back to it this one's
like you open it and you're basically
that's it I like the flavor of this but
I love what this represents to me that's
fair
[Music]
this is called a born chick okay so it's
basically like a doughnut except there's
no like glaze on it um the most popular
one has Nutella inside and people really
love that usually when you get it at the
store there's like different fillings
you can get it with this is just a basic
filling you can get it with an Oreo
inside you can get it with Nutella
inside when you eat it warm and get like
you're biting into air first fast
I hate donut really yeah it's very
Safari I don't think I've ever met
somebody that food so I don't like that
but everyone looks so nice it's an
American classic and we're in America so
this is the original glazed doughnut
it's not from Krispy Kreme you got your
your fried dough with a full punched in
it and then your sugar stuff on top of
it
now what's gonna sway to sweet
[Music]
our fully perfect it's really good
there's a fantastic huh and this isn't
not fantastic I mean I love a donut I
really do love a donut this doll is
pretty good it's a donut everybody loves
Donuts except her apparently but yeah I
do I do like those better
they're so good when they're like warm
and like I don't know I like the feeling
and bite especially like in chocolate
try the chocolate one no this is really
the perfect dessert you heard it here
first folks
mhm a perfect dessert it's so good I
came in was like this is gonna be good
food always looks good when I Drive past
it all the time all the pretty photos
but snacks are actually amazing and
perfectly sweet perfectly favorite never
too much never too little it's amazing
like they know what they're doing I feel
like here we're just kind of like you
know literally and figuratively most
people make these things at home like
the bone cheese they make at home the
ton you can make at home the bed eggs
you can definitely make at home Armenian
food is fantastic that yogurt drink is
like it's an acquired taste but I can
see why it everyone loves it I'm flying
to Armenia
it's time to get married honey I'm
playing games i keel you like this all
the time and this is just like the
snacks imagine the food I'm sure